all right welcome to this video it's a
15 minute game again here on ICC and I
play d4 and we get a Queen's Gambit
let's see what line his is going for
only others laughs yeah
all right I'm always a bit of arguing
myself with myself I should play the
exchange because it's yeah it's not the
most exciting line but I have such a
huge score but I really should play it
yeah he's going for the complete
symmetrical answer Bishop f5 and yeah
couldn't be three ously the only way to
to test like a bit here Bishop b5 is
also possible but then 97's okay from
like yeah Bishop before us also the best
move and we should be 5 volts on the
only move that promises wide some yeah
some try for an advantage so it's fairly
symmetrical now but then like an hour
yeah this is again the right move there
are alternatives but this is this is
fine okay woopsie 8 yeah black might
intend to move the night away 95
something like this it's changing a bit
of material yeah so should I move the
Queen let's say 2 to a 3 or something
intending to maybe take c6 take a 7
yeah it's a possibility or just rook c1
yeah but rook c1 you might really play
95 this could be a bit bit annoying so I
want to move the Queen out of this this
night this night discoveries so what can
you play now I could play Queen b6 would
be one idea okay a six yeah the question
is does it make any sense to preserve
this Bishop I move like Bishop b2 and
I'm not sure and Bishop e2 we might play
something also like Bishop g4 it's not
not clear that I don't want to make it
maybe I just want to take on c6 trying
to be a bit quicker on the C file which
just may be possible okay now try that
and rook FC one the next move
yeah of course I need to check with rook
okay now whoopsie one so I think I'm a
bit quicker on the C file now if he
plays the move light will be six I have
fun
95
okay yeah this was another idea I
thought that maybe just be three now
should be okay intending to take and
play Lucy one on 95 was similar yeah of
course with the exchange you cannot
expect to win any games with with mating
attacks
well sometimes you manage even that but
it's usually the kind of line we tried
to press for a very small advantage like
yeah being quicker on the C file and so
on I must say that he played to rather
good defense though I mean I've won lots
of games quickly in the exchange even
where people simply didn't know I'm any
kind of theory and they got into into
huge trouble
really quickly so takes now and Roxy won
guess so also 95 is also also an idea
the question is why would you move the
Queen maybe Queen B 595 Queen b6 I can
take on a fade yeah this is a neat
little trick which it's not
no not quite sure I think I should play
Roxie one first it belongs there anyway
okay going to be six so how to
continuous this night is a bit offside
and I'd like to of course an infiltrate
on the sea farm
Bishop d6 maybe Bishop d6 we're up c7 he
can play Queen d5 which isn't terrible
for me but it doesn't really help
another idea is Queen e7 but I don't
really want to allow him to take on a
farm
I think this what would help like maybe
this first
my dis to play queen is 7 so queen is 7
now okay can play rook e8 okay some
maybe start with 95 but he can play f6
okay wait wait wait
Knight e5 f6 can I take on f8 Queen f8
King f8 Bishop d6 check and then rook c8
is media oh this is nice yeah it's
really working right okay so I can't
play this move it cannot play f6 because
of Queen f8 check Bishop d6 check King
moves and rook c8 mate on mate next move
and then it's tender smooth this time is
certainly ok I'm threatened g4 and
possibly also Queen e7 really invading
and f6 queen of 80s you can easily miss
that
maybe he'll you play that nice little
trap yeah I have a little something here
in this position quick on the sea fall
and it's a bit a bit a bit badly
coordinated here
what should he play maybe rook c8 maybe
something like this okay
the squeal of a truck is really neat but
it's not really work
oh wait wait wait wait wait I need to
check this if it would work it would be
really beautiful Queen f8 King takes
Bishop d6 check King e a truck za
dismayed if he goes to g8 I play rook c8
check 98 and a 4 and a 4
how does he protect the bishop the night
only 8 how does he protect the night
with his queen the queen is attacked he
cannot I think this is just winning is
winning and a4 come on I think this
should I think it's really working maybe
I'm just seeing a ghost here
yeah now King g8 is the only move King
edge rook c8 is easy
check Knight needs to drop back I'm
still haha I'm stupid
you can play Queen e8 we can play Queen
e8 and then it's a draw or at least I've
got nothing this is the problem
yeah okay I should have looked a little
bit deeper but 98 a force winning 98 a
for think swinging I attacked the Queen
it cannot cover cover the night and aunt
I'm winning but Queenie a to have the
system does a silly car too bad yeah the
thing is um if things like these are so
so close to working then maybe it's
something else was possible very very
likely really okay so this is really
yeah less than nothing
yeah okay I need to take you home and
this is some really am absolutely dead
equal position the only very small idea
is 97 to c5 it might be something in
this right but he can play Knight f6 a
stupid okay
this was really neat and then he's just
got Queen e8 okay now but let's let's
try on 9725 yeah okay so 97 he covered I
think I played this taking those squares
a 44 and intending g45 winning some
space
g5 now night to where yeat yeah I can
play there this is hanging also this is
a problem yeah I can play g5 9075 but
you can just take a - and I haven't
really made any progress so need to do
this first but now it's got King e7 yeah
I'm not sure why not seven alright is
there any idea
yeah ninety-seven next move really sucks
all light of life out of the position I
don't even have a square for this night
where I could could could could go just
to avoid you the exchange yeah okay well
this is just a draw what can I do
yeah played this Queen f8 really am a
bit too quickly
should have looked a bit deeper if
there's something something better
yeah this is just dead really not not
much each side can do you can play
Bishop c2 before and then advance with
the King draw offered the only idea that
I have has sown entering with the King
on f6 this is very hard to imagine that
chances would would work hmm let's think
about this is there some way at least to
to try in this position getting to f6 to
g7 yeah is it wrong
some tricks at least okay
uh-huh not sure if I like this move okay
so this means that my queen side will be
safe I can I can play Bishop Bishop to
f8 and form f8 i always covered before
and then I can maybe really try to
invade with the king it's just um yeah
okay we can we can always put the King
on the 8 and just just do nothing this
is the real problem I guess
yeah black and just put the King on yet
and play Bishop c4 d3 till hell freezes
over
I just want to see what what he's doing
maybe he'll get some some some great
ideas instead of doing doing nothing
doing something not sure that I have
should have the bishop on g7 this is a
potential scrap for my king so I better
put it to c5 yeah I can I can try really
to to to get the H pawn here the
question is I should I should I should
try to play playing aged five first
maybe allows me to play h6 and then I
can really walk all the way walk all the
way through should I play also if for
this is also I wait wait wait this is
also an idea as I do this first I play
before before and King e5 if he takes
I'll I'll get a passed pawn at least
with d5
efore king e5 uh-huh well this is a pawn
I'll take this so okay let's let's
protect the point first before thinking
about about other things and now if
foreign King e5 right okay can protect
this with Bishop c4 maybe it is still um
still a fortress possible
hmmm maybe it's still a fortress M yeah
how to make any progress here maybe yeah
this Bishop is somewhat vulnerable here
can I put it somewhere else
also I could could try to just walk to
c5 I think playing if I really am
doesn't do me much good but I could play
King F 45 but this is just too closed I
guess yeah this must be a draw okay try
to get the King to c5
okay so now I think he needs to move his
king can I now regroup this Bishop to e5
or something let's try this okay
okay maybe here I don't really see them
see a way to to make progress so I've
taught me my Bishop to g5 but it's not
like a huge step forward
yeah last last idea getting the King to
h6
hmm yeah not the most exciting ever and
game yeah of course this was also an
idea but now I would actually get the
age poem okay yeah if five looks nice
but it's so closed after that so so the
only way okay it is a draw anyway but
let's try try with taking time morning
job black just has a fortress here no
way to to make any progress
yeah this F I think was really weird but
seemed that it was okay
draw awkward okay game drawn
yeah yeah what can you do the five was
really a really strange that you can
afford that but maybe you can I
I played something something something
stupid now I don't know I know maybe
it's still a draw I mean it's it's very
dry yeah the bad thing here was really
my queen sec the queen sec i mean white
is just better in this position and
after this it's a draw pretty sure with
what normal moves I can just play on
Queenie seven for example and black is
really tied down to have seven and
threatening Bishop Bishop d6 and so on I
mean this is just better for white and I
had this this neat idea with with the
SEC but so we look the simple Queenie
898 if force is a nice win yeah I got a
little bit carried away after seeing
this idea and well after what I played
oh let's not say what he played after
this Queen e8 we got this this Huber end
game where there's simply nothing to do
I mean oh this is really not the best
way to play it but it's may be
sufficient
let's check this hopefully f5 amazing
I don't think you needed to do that but
okay yeah that's really not much to do
it's just a draw
yeah thanks for watching anyway I hope
you enjoyed at least this is neat little
matrix with with a4 and yeah he defended
well after this what can you do